yeah so there's this interesting
phenomena that is very characteristic of
societies I believe pretty much
everywhere it's being studied now you
can calculate an index called the Gini
coefficient and the Gini coefficient is
a number that represents how much
inequality of income distribution there
is in a given geographical area so you
could calculate a Gini coefficient for a
street or you know an area in the city
or a city or a state or a country you
can do it at all those levels and what
you find is you know you owns here this
idea that poverty causes crime that's a
classic left-wing idea but it's wrong
it's seriously wrong and it's
importantly wrong and it's definitively
wrong not only that so there's no
argument about this it's already been
established
what causes crime especially aggressive
crime is relative poverty and relative
poverty is not the same thing as poverty
at all it's seriously not the same thing
poverty is when you don't have enough to
eat relative poverty is when the guy
next door has a much better car than you
so and there's lots of relative poverty
in the United States and there's some
absolute poverty but even the absolute
poverty in the United States is nothing
like the absolute poverty say in places
like India or in sub-saharan Africa
where absolute poverty means you have
nothing now what's really interesting
about the Gini coefficient is that if
you go to places where everyone roughly
speaking is it poor say by national
standards right I think South Dakota was
often used as an example or maybe one of
the Maritime Provinces like Newfoundland
where there's where there's low average
income but it's pretty flat distribution
there's almost no crime and if you go to
places where the everyone's rich then
there's almost no crime but if you go
places where there are poor people and
moderately well-off people and rich
people and the distribution is really
steep then the rate of aggressive
behavior among young men and it's
usually within their own ethnic group
starts to suck sky
out of control and the reason for that
seems to be that if the dominant
hierarchy is too steep then the young
men have no likelihood of climbing to a
dominant position while playing the
standard social game and so what they do
is turn to aggression aggression to to
make their mark on the world and it
works too
that's the other thing is that make no
mistake about it if you're if you're
looking for status in a place where
status is hard to achieve and you're the
meanest toughest guy around then and you
know around a bunch of people who like
you don't have much money then you're
going to benefit from that status it
works yeah
because the parvis reason why we know
the attitude violent crime rate in the
u.s. is higher than it is in Canada we
got big part of the reason sure sure
yeah I mean you can make a real
conservative argument for making sure
that you know the Conservatives are very
anti income distribution and we figure
that's because of the guys that have
this male independence you know they
identify with this male independence
factor they don't want to be
distributing resources to people who are
down the dolmen turkey because they want
they want them down in the dorm inner
turkey they want there to be a
difference between the people on top and
the people on the bottom so that they
can be the people on top so that it
increases their relative attractiveness
like it's a perfectly logical game and
they presume that while the rules are
set up and like every man can go for it
do its best in the winter wins and the
loser loses and that's just how it is
and don't ask me to fix it because I
don't want it you know and besides that
it's I don't find it I find it
distasteful to attempt to fix it more
than that right because it's a moral
issue it's not just that an intellectual
issue so so you can make a case however
you can make a case from the
conservative point of view especially
with regards to say beliefs in religious
traditionalism and the desire to
maintain social stability that you
shouldn't let income distribution become
too unequal like one of the big things
your society has to do is to make sure
that that doesn't get out of hand
because it tends to get out of hand it
tends towards a few people having
everything and almost everyone else
having nothing it's a natural in a sense
it's a natural consequence of
economic progression which is actually
something that Marx pointed out although
an Italian named perrito and figured it
out at approximately the same time and I
think with a lot more conceptual clarity
but the more unequal you let your
society get to higher the probability of
death roughly speaking through violent
causes and no but but but I'll tell you
why is that you know men want to climb
the dominant turkey and the reason they
want to calm the dominant turkeys
because that's how they get access to
women societies actually have earlier in
this discussion you talking both
familiar and the unfamiliar and the
structure so it seems like we all want
it within the structure of me no one too
little to apply for as well well we have
this contradictory problem we want to be
protected by the structure but we want
to advance our position within it and so
that means what that should mean and
this is I think the definition of
civilized behavior is that you're
allowed to advance your position within
the structure as long as you don't
disrupt it negatively you know and I
think most people do do that in fact I
think people in civilized countries do
that so effectively that it's an
absolute incomprehensible miracle I
can't understand how or why I never got
established but like a psychopath will
he climb the ladder and cut the runs off
underneath fundamentally right it's like
he doesn't care he doesn't even care if
the damn thing maintains itself you know
he's perfectly willing to have it
destroyed after he's exhausted it you
know but if everyone acted like that or
even if a fairly substantial percentage
of people acted like that the whole
thing would come to a halt virtually
it's like in no time flat so so mean why
see you might here here's the reasons
likely you know because one of the
things we were talking about with
masculine violence now the thing about
masculine violence is it only tends to
emerge in situations where there does
there don't seem to be any other
reasonably viable means of advancing
status so it's not reasonable to say
that men are aggressive you can say that
on average men are more aggressive than
women and you can also say that if that
if you put men in a situation where they
have no where they can see status
differences but they have no means of
moving forward that they're likely to
turn to aggression as a way of
establishing dominance and then you can
say that that's the reason for that is
because it makes them more attractive
what the fundamental reason yeah oh yeah
bring that on foul I read this article
once about the hollow of women society
no more volatile yeah absolutely
just a week they live with one guy how
do I fit into the conversation
that's right do i versus them yeah
that's exactly right that evolutionary
psychology explanation for the pathology
of polygamy is that if once you let it
establish itself then the men get
ultraviolent
so would you say that
many people have said that and yes I
think you can make a strong case for
that and I think the fundamental reason
is the one that you just pointed out you
know the idea is well would you rather
have one woman or die you know or sorry
that's not quite right would you rather
no that's not quite that's not quite
right would you it's more like would you
be willing to limit yourself to one
partner or have a shot at many partners
but a much higher probability of dying
Yeah right and you know some guys will
take that they'll take that the high
risk approach you know so now it just
doesn't eliminate the difference in
individual differences in determining
who's going to be aggressive because
what will happen is that as the Gini
coefficient pressure rises the more
aggressive men the men who are more
aggressive by nature will get more
aggressive first right so you can
imagine it's a threshold phenomena to
some sense so and what I should tell you
as well is the relationship between the
Gini coefficient and male-on-male on the
side isn't like 0.2 or 0.3 which is
about the correlation that you get if
you were predicting something like that
using personality
it's like point eight or point nine it's
like idiot of all of it it's the
explanation so it's a huge effect you
know it's so it's so big in effect that
you can basically say oh well we figured
that out all those psychologists never
know when they figured anything out and
they keep endlessly retesting it over
and over and over because you know we
don't know how to bring our science to a
stop but if you don't accept the Gini
coefficient aggression data it's like
you might as well throw the rest of
social sciences out the window because
then the effect is unbelievably powerful
hilarious it depends you can do it at
any level of analysis you can do it you
can do it by county you can do it by
city you can do it by state and you can
do with my country and it works on all
of those levels for me you bet yeah yeah
and that's a great question I mean the
method logically sophisticated studies
have done exactly that to ensure that
while to ensure that it's actually this
phenomena rather than other factors that
might be offered in that particular
geographical area so countries with a
higher Gini coefficient or more violent
and cities within that country that have
a higher than average Gini coefficient
for that country are more violent on
average it's a very very robust robust
robust finding so all right so we're
going to say for the sake of argument
that you've got the male dominance
hierarchy and it's represented as
masculine now one of the things you said
he thought that women carried an image
of math men in their unconscious and she
he thought that the image that women
carried of men in their unconscious was
a group of men not an individual man he
called that the animus whereas he
believed that the image that women image
of women that men carry in their
collective unconscious was of a single
woman and he called that the anima